[Música]
experto novato impostor bartenders hola
soy alisa y yo soy motoki y esto es
fraude aficionado o experto e
intentaremos averiguar quién es el
experto y quién es todo un frío y
entrevistaremos a 3
compongo
parte muy bien los más asombrosos del
planeta
supongo que nos vamos a poner un poco
eléctricos vas a tener que beber por mí
la verdad no bebo soy muy tranquila y
sobria
eso está bien
bueno
como cada fin de semana trabajé en un
restaurante y me hice muy buena amiga
del bartender y él era el mejor amigo
del estado adjunto de decir son casi
terapeuta es una buena señal para un
parte en this is podría ser mi terapeuta
[Música]
machado
están cansados por el trasnocho
de despertar para la primera ronda
pueden hacer unos shorts
con algunos shows y
muy bien
este es un shot
mixto no es tan espirituoso no sabrás
solo a alcohol
huele muy bien vaya pusiste pepino de la
forma en que se viene no terminaste
se ve muy bonito y actual para la
temporada de ahora si es
divertido es un borde
bueno bueno vamos experto novato
impostor podrías explicarnos de que es
tuyo es un show de tequila tiki jarabe
de maracuyá un poco de jarabe de coco
reposado y jugo de limón con un poco de
tajín en el borde huele muy bien creo
que te va gustar bueno salud gracias
estoy ebrio
bueno tiene un agradable sabor amargo
tomaré sólo un trago más pequeño soy por
favor el
experto novato impostor nada muy
elegante tras un juego con un whisky
sureño un poco de borbón y de albahaca
pero el trabajo de un show es embriagar
cierto y éste lo hará tu estilo es muy
clásico se mantiene simple pero fuerte
bueno cuando estás haciendo alto volumen
en un bar y no hay que deslumbrar debes
hacerlo rápido
[Música]
o es muy dulce es bueno pensé que
tendría un sabor más parecido al alcohol
puro y lo recomendaría experto novato
impostor dinos que nos prepárense es el
show de tarta de manzana se trata de una
onza de sidra de manzana una onza de
fútbol y un poco de crema batida es con
una rama de calles precioso soy una rica
básica de otoño
starbucks pendientes gorila así sería yo
solía trabajar para ellos de verdad sí
como todo el mundo ahora tengo una
versión al sabor fireball debido a una
experiencia traumática en la universidad
pero por el bien del vídeo
esto
me siento la universidad
en la universidad
es cuando bebes demasiado y puedes
hacerte daño debe ser mayor de edad para
beber y espero que tengas edad para
beber
ronda dos cócteles preparen su cóctel
favorito si el que más les guste uno que
sea popular me gusta trabajar con el
pepino frescas así se obtiene la esencia
del pepino en el vodka
[Risas]
muévelo muévelo muévelo
como una especie de cobaya terminaste
bien eres rápido eres rápido observamos
desde el principio un golpecito para ti
que tan importante es la presentación es
lindo esa es mi parte favorita pero el
amor a ti mismo es bueno para cuando
tomes el primer sorbo sientas un toque
de limón no de lima prepara tu palabra
recuerdo muy bien el bar del número de
vídeo esto se ve precioso esta es mi
aura seguramente
dónde conseguiste esta pita ya sé en
realidad las hago yo mismo eres buenas
con sus clientes
muy bien estoy probando varias cosas
está presente el pepino también lo pitó
yo un poco de licor de naranja pajín
muchas gracias un trabajo increíble muy
bien que vino hacia el padre se llama
kevin buen nombre
es algo que es bastante simple es tipo
estándar como una versión del lado este
esta es como un vodka jugo de lima es
fácil de hacer
en un bote de pepino
me encanta de ahí es mi madre también
eres mi padre
en esto de las bebidas
te gustó en realidad tiene cualidades
similares a la anterior ley
tiene tu estilo muy similar es de esos
cócteles donde no no estás tan sola el
secreto es hacer que los cócteles sean
fáciles de preparar para el bartender y
fáciles de beber para el cliente y de
james necesitan más
micaela qué es esto tan bonito dinos el
nombre se llama aviondepapel pero me
gusta llamarlo puesta de sol italiana
porque lleva muchos licores italianos
como el borbón amaro que es un licor de
hierbas y luego campario puedes usar
aperol si lo quieres un poco más dulce
lo notarás bastar un pcb verlo quiero
verte sostener la copa sólo por
diversión sostenida de como sostener el
ingenio
así lo calentará más rápido depende en
serio
es un dato interesante y me siento como
el gran gatsby
crees que un bartender lo sabría o que
cualquiera sabría eso de cales salido es
como es como un buen algo en qué pensar
está fuerte
déjame oler
[Música]
mi mural y
[Risas]
ronda 3 elección del bartender esto va a
ser muy divertido para ustedes chicos
libre para todos muy bien que comiencen
los juegos amigos
empezó el juego
porque es lo más gratificante para ti
como bartender mi lenguaje de amor es
más bien el negocio de la hospitalidad
sólo contribuyó a que todo el mundo la
pase bien acceso se trata comida
diversión recuerdo diversión y
bueno me hace sentir bien así tenemos a
nuestro veloz y no
sí un poco
bueno mi madre y mi padre bueno
terminaste si el hostal pestis traemos a
lulú porque
lo que hiciste un manhattan me gusta
para terminar la noche esta es tu copa
favorita así es mi favorita es usado
tres veces dos veces
de acuerdo vaya es una rodaja de piña sí
es una piña asada deshidratado
las clásicas guarniciones de lulú parece
una flor es una margarita de piña con
jalapeños hecha con un reposado y luego
por supuesto tajín porque es la
tradicional nos encanta el tajín hasta
el fondo esto
está bueno siento que esto sería una
buena bebida de barbacoa bailar o la
barbacoa saborear el ahumado de la
barbacoa con piña porque la guarnición
realza los ingredientes con la esencia
ahora recibe es el olor cuando la bebida
otras sensaciones me siento como si
estuviera en una barbacoa donde está mi
primo
muy bien que este es un cóctel muy muy
clásico y sencillo conocido como mulá
seguro ya sólo hablar de la mula es lo
que me llevó a hacer bartender es una
simple mula de ken tóxico no un más que
lo de moscú es con vodka la de canto que
es como ésta es la única bebida que no
bebería porque pienso si bebiera bebería
una música es muy sencilla de hacer y no
requiere mucho tiempo es un beneficio y
a la gente de verdad le encanta los
moodle de a quien toque las raíces de
kentucky estaba una vez más bastante
similar a sus otras bebidas el hielo
siempre es importante sé que algunas
personas son quisquillosos con el hilo
me gustan mis tragos con hielo porque
resaltan el sabor de la mayoría de los
alcoholes lulu estabas a punto de decir
el hielo es vital
bueno no el hielo hueco y fino porque
una vez que lo agitas automáticamente
dañas la bebida hablando de hielo no
háblanos de él les hice un manjar dan 2
onzas de borbón una onza de vermont
dulce para que no tenga el sabor amargo
del borbón luego un poco de amargo y una
cereza dulce en la parte superior para
equilibrarlo y se revuelve en el hielo
para que esté frío
si es alcohol
[Risas]
bien me gusta hablar mucho con tus
clientes sí porque cuanto más hablan
beben un poco más rápido y se
entretienen es lo que te hizo querer ser
bartender bueno empecé a trabajar en
estado despierto y simplemente me gustó
la creatividad de trabajar bajo presión
el servicio al cliente y la gente está
más contenta cuando le das alcohol a las
6 de la mañana a la noche sí eso fue
todo en la ronda final sí esa fue la
ronda final todos ustedes hicieron un
trabajo increíble
maravillosos
deliberación fue divertido muy divertido
también fue un poco intimidante sí
porque los bartenders son geniales es
difícil decirlo porque al mismo tiempo
como el alcohol es un poco subjetivo
aunque no me gusta una bebida no es que
esté mal hecho por supuesto obviamente
te los estaba saliendo
así es las bebidas de micaela me
parecieron únicas
definitivamente siento que ella fue
algún tipo de escuela ahora kevin kevin
era
o muy casero
siento que fue muy práctico y dijiste
que la mayoría de sus bebidas habían
igual sí que te pareció 'lulu' ella me
sorprendió con la piña deshidratada y
esas cosas y los de lulú me parecieron
geniales el sabor era increíble la
presentación fue espectacular pero al
mismo tiempo cualquiera en interés o
tick tock podría haber un tutorial y
recrearlo yo diría que los lunes
diría que aficionado aficionado bueno
[Risas]
déjame tomar otro sorbo
si toma un sorbo y luego dime es una
bebida de aficionado
[Música]
el resultado
en
bienvenidos de nuevo el experto pensamos
que es
lulú tenías un conocimiento tan amplio
no sólo de las bebidas que hacías sino
que hacías tus propias guarniciones y
las habas e hidratadas y en cuanto a
presentación fue genial y si no eres la
experta entonces nos engañaste si nos
engañan
buen trabajo chicos
ella cuando tenía 21 años fui a la
escuela de coctelería y desde entonces
literalmente ese ha sido mi trabajo soy
bartender mezcladora consultora de
bebidas bar móvil de una empresa de
catering con mi propia marca estar en el
sector de la hostelería especialmente
ahora puede ser muy duro si vas a
aprender a hacer tragos pero también
tienes la capacidad de tener control
paciencia con los clientes de explicar
las cosas a tus bartenders a tu personal
eso es lo principal que enseño a mis
alumnos antes incluso de que se pongan
detrás de la barra soy le aficionado
aquí es donde se pone difícil vamos con
micaela y por qué está usando un
delantal
siendo barista al principio también
parece una transición perfecta
muy bien no juzgues un delantal por ti
trabajé para estar books pero solo
frente a la computadora soy analista me
gusta preparar bebidas en la universidad
preparaba mojitos a mi compañero de
cuarto y me gusta prepararme un buen
whisky antes de dormir no tengo
experiencia como bartender durante la
cuarentena por el convite y si algunas
bebidas en casa no solo vodka y cerveza
de raíz sino cosas con algo de fruta y
demás
lucha será muy contigo eres el
aficionado
tienes una gran confianza en ti mismo y
al principio cuando vi a todos por
primera vez me dije expert sin buque si
ibas muy rápido y todo eso pensábamos
que estabas no sé tratando de engañarnos
por tender por años ya no estudio
tubería durante diez años hasta hace
poco he desempeñado puestos desde
bartender hasta gerente de alimentos y
bebidas mi primer trabajo de bartender
fue en un club nocturno donde era capaz
de sacar tragos no lo hiciste
humanamente posible eso es lo que tienes
que hacer fue divertido miraba sus
bebidas pensaba oh eso se ve muy bien y
luego miraba a micaela y pensaba oh esto
también se ve muy bien dije los vinos se
ven muy feos ellas ganarán gracias por
el gran de los guisos estuvieron todos
increíbles buen trabajo
[Aplausos]
[Música]